hello and happy Valentine's Day
everybody I'm Michelle Miller and we're
in the CBS this morning Toyota greenroom
with Melissa Hobley the chief marketing
officer of dating platform okay thank
you man the company made a splash with
their DTF campaign which seeks to
redefine what the s in the popular
phrase means the ads encourage people to
connect over things like hobbies and
politics and there's a whole lot of
other stuff you're trying to make
connections on a lot welcome Melissa
thanks for having me and Happy
Valentines
okay red lip that's the read ready to
have a doob a hot night planned or is it
like I don't I'm a bad person
what fine let's talk love anyway let's
talk low so that campaign was rather
provocative it was I mean you were
pushing the envelope here it was
provocative it was provocative and
here's what happened I'm OkCupid Haddon
has been around for over 15 years so we
know a little bit about dating we're
very good at this but we were coming up
with something about a year ago and a
year and a few months ago is when Michi
was really coming in to our psyche right
and really having a moment and driving
all these important conversations
especially for young women and women who
are working and we wanted to connect to
what was happening in the world so let's
talk about you you're trying to appeal
to a younger audience but with still
trying to keep the the old folks like
yeah but but really the acronym there
when my producer Jessica Kay who told me
there was an at there's like that's an
actual DTF is what those those are
Millennials they they're just like over
the top they're over the top of
Millennials so what does that mean
without and there's a new phrase every
day Jeff yeah it means down to what is
yes
accident and here's the important thing
Michelle is is it was a label that guys
used to talk to other guys about girls
so it was not a label that you said
right this is how I describe myself I
want in on this it was not that it was a
derogatory it was an objectified it
wasn't
they're exactly right and so yeah we
wanted to say hey
come try OkCupid whether you're 18 or 89
because we serve all ages but we we
wanted to do something that promoted a
conversation right so DTF was about
changing the F and make the F whatever
the f you want to show so down to
falling in love mom
down to the farmers market down to
finish your novel because a lot of
especially 20s and 30s some things you
might work at news or you might work in
marketing writing their writing you
might have a store in epsy you knit you
know mittens for dogs I don't know
whatever you want to do the side hustle
is great so your but the point is it's
whatever you want it to be and the
beautiful thing it is ties to like
OkCupid is about which is whatever
you're into we want to match on that
okay OkCupid you said been around 15
years ago yeah I wasn't aware that you
are the oldest dating website is that
you're one of only a few of us there
yeah I won't name the rest around as
long as I'm kinky but you're also trying
to get away from the swipe left
mentality it's it's not just about this
it's about this it's about this yes well
you care about what you look if you are
into animal rescue and that's your
passion we're one of the only dating
apps that can actually use an algorithm
to find other people that will support
that in leavener maybe they do it too
and politics isn't off the limit
politics is not off limits we are seeing
one of the most interesting shifts in
dating in the last like 40 years is the
role of politics and dating and we have
because we've been around a long time
and we were started by Harvard math
grads so we're all about watching the
data and helping that make do a better
job of matching people and again we're
really good at this we're one of the
most successful at getting people
together but we started noticing
something as the elect the 2016 election
heated up and that was the explosion of
political terms on your profile and what
I mean by that is people saying I really
care about about this if you aren't
uninterested deal-breaker deal-breaker
or if you don't vote don't reach out
don't match I'm a wow it's Bethany and
how how beautiful is that though right
because especially Millennials however
have a pretty bad reputation for being
shallow
parents baster it is about this I'm not
about like what's going on here and to
say that those issues what you care
about that you vote that you're into
climate change or not whatever that may
be we really leaned into and it's it's
Cree it's literally creating love oh so
it's not just a hey there you're not
gonna get her a spot to the hey there
you have an almost 90% chance of being
totally ignored if your first message is
getting out is hey okay let's talk about
how you've opened things up you really
opened the door on LGBTQ issues and in
particular I found it really interesting
it's the first page is do you identify
woman man and then you have an option
bar yeah and that's when I I I knew
nothing about Who I am when I went to
the option bar so just I love that page
it's like well I open to how you
identify and how you feel are you
heterosexual your sexual orientation
that's right we serve 23 you are good
you have been on OkCupid we serve 22
gender options with you to teen sexual
orientation options tomorrow might be 23
we enable you to choose a few we were
the first dating app to enable big
dating app to enable users to state the
pronoun by which they identify we are we
are incredibly proud of the OkCupid for
a long time has served LGBTQ and by the
way if you are in a small town or you're
not in New York City where we are today
it might be hard to find someone safely
that also was your sexual orientation
right and dating apps enabled that and
they powered it and and we're very proud
of that to this day LGBTQ is an
important community that we serve and
and you know we're always gonna figure
out how to do a good job there do you
have millennial sort of given up on the
dating app who is this popular what
still yeah right now is popular with
everyone really I'm not kidding 1889
three out of five why not is why not 90
enough sure I think we have a new
business they're all ages I you know
three out of five marriages today come
from and eating up well so my
my hairdresser met her husband on a date
I love it it's just but here's what I
thought was really interesting now I I
thought you you really reached out at a
time when a lot of people needed sort of
a helping hand the shutdown I call you
shutdown friendly yeah because you sort
of like catered to what was probably a
very what was a very stressful time a
lot of it wasn't stressful time a lot of
people and we loved seeing immediately
saw few people like Jose hydride Trump
and say we want to offer food and we
said well what can we do well date
nights we know how to do a date night so
we immediately went to a few bars in DC
and we said come in show your federal ID
and we'll buy not one drink not one beer
a few and we actually some of us went
down there we just started buying food
we heard from one couple he's like I
would love to news we don't have a
babysitter so we we gave him money for a
babysitter really no I think the beauty
is we are so proud of like facilitating
love so let's do that especially when
people need it well Melissa hobbly we
really appreciate you coming to talk to
us this is so fun this is all about
OkCupid trying to kick it up a notch I
think so happy Valentine's Day happy
v-day we're talking love thank you